this is the absolute worst buzzfeed
video i have ever been
[Music]
i'm scared i'm scared now too dogs
what's up i'm andrew i'm david hi i'm
michelle hi i'm destiny i feel like that
meme and the dog sitting when the house
is on fire like this is fine
everything's fine oh no
it's fine
[Music]
is this saw
beyonce or rihanna
really that's the warm-up question
beyonce or rihanna
late registration helped me get through
a breakup at a tough part of my life
[Music]
oh um
i was like he really thinking about this
like this is a deep question
um
flower
yeah let's go flour let's go [ __ ] yeah i
messed with flour
uh i'm haitian i eat suck up fat so i
gotta say rice we eat that like three
times a week so yeah i'll support you in
that decision west africa wait what
flour or spinach
if i had to eat it plain i'd go with
spinach
that's my final answer
vietnamese are japanese probably
japanese
it's tough though because i love a good
bolafa
but like i feel like i'm kind of a picky
eater and i think japanese food has uh
more food that like my
childish taste buds can take so japanese
food
tofu definitely go with the tofu
beyond me there's a hateful but it ain't
that good you could fry him up get you a
little nice slice of extra firm you bit
like how many cubes to fill you up bro
like look you that little thing in there
you slice him up that's a lot of little
cubes in there you ain't never unwrap
the package hey you ain't a rapping
package when the last time
okay uh bacon because i had spam once i
didn't love it believe it or not
everyone loves spam i know but i just i
didn't love it it's in a can okay but
how did you how did you have spam the
way everybody told me straight out the
can
i would say lentils i appreciate the
taste a little bit um you know beans i
feel like of course really filling the
lentils i kind of feel like give me that
happy medium you know what i'm saying
that's sophisticated decision
um lentils are chickpeas
oh i do okay chickpeas then for the
hummus gourmet cheese or regular cheese
i'm gonna go gourmet okay i was gonna
judge you yeah yeah
let me get some american cheese slices i
am bougie and i love a good gourmet meal
i am also severely lactose intolerant
so
[Music]
i'm gonna go with soap
squash or corn
oh i hate squash corn
i'm gonna say squash
i'ma say squash avocados
avocados because without avocados you
can't have guac
avocados okay even though avocados are
overrated
[Music]
apples
[Music]
oh watermelon
watermelon
i feel like you said that too fast you
ain't gonna think about that
[Music]
what if i told you you weren't actually
playing this or that you were building a
burrito
and we're gonna have to eat all these
things that we chose shut the hell up
just sit tight there a little bit talk
about yourselves
michelle
okay everything's not fine
oh they're coming forward oh god oh no
i'm sorry
oh wait it looks like so as we've been
speaking there's been someone just
cooking up in the back what we've been
saying for a while look the way i had a
ticket
i know
[Music]
this is crazy and i see your avocado
made appearance i see apple and i see a
watermelon i'm like this is yours
because all your choices is in this one
i'm so sad
okay remember when we were talking about
like oh it's a surprise what could the
surprise be and i was like haha what if
it was like beyonce walking out with a
bowl of guac because that's what we
chose this is like the opposite of that
whatever the opposite of beyonce and
guacamole this is how bad this is we're
gonna do this you know we're just gonna
all right bro
[Music]
it's interesting i'm not really sure
what's going on
but i'm not hella mad i'm not mad either
i'm mad i'm not mad it's not gonna be
okay it's disgusting girl get ready for
the aftertaste too okay you're not
helping
that's noodles and watermelon and blue
cheese and corn and avocado and bacon
in that order
wait she gets an option i'm not trying
overall i'm satisfied like tasty y'all
some wizards man because i'm trying to
tell you on paper this is terrible but
yeah like if you was to read this at a
what would you even call this on a menu
a wtf burrito
would you like our um let's see
brunch house party burrito i like this
it's a brunch that's how we bought it
it's a brunch because it's like you got
the watermelon and the fruit like right
if you guys could give this a name
the garbage can
yeah it sounds all right yeah
garbage can finish wrapped garbage can
whatever is in the garbage disposal this
is the absolute worst buzzfeed video i
have ever been
don't call me back
[Laughter]
oh yes
you